I'm Joshua and I'm a lawyer so you sent
people to jail yes yes for what the
murder working inside the courts
completely demystifies that the judge
behind it a very deep bench roamed
incredibly intelligent and eccentric
people its lair it is fantastic
they're all very particular how they
would like the bench set up small
post-it notes to color burrows playing
paper photos of family Chris I feel so
scared
guilty I challenge you to rap about
javo'''s which which are which which are
path of the robes that barristers and
judges we're two long strips justice
bullfrogs testicles lovely so Jabez
justice and a bullfrogs testicles yes
let's do this yo I see him right there
hanging down from your neck like her
Civic hair like ringlets I see a most so
taut neatly Preston is the other jab
Beau's a wife going down there and I
must discuss when you explain it but I
think a Jabba the Hutt I know it felt
very differently but I got Star Wars on
the brain you see but Geoff Bowes like
white lands in the middle of a road like
Grandmaster Flash was no year talk about
the lands of cocaine but the land like a
telephone cord to the brain Barris there
make sure they hang there otherwise the
uniformed police to stop and stare and
be like a sartorial elegance you fail
gonna send your ass straight to jail
yeah
and in there it will be odd you get a
cell mate with testicles like a
bullfrogs
I mean big bulbous and toad ish yeah
being a prison then you will know this
you find it hard to sleep under your
quilt see when Joshua
glunk says guilty if like no get into
jail trying to claw out with the spoon
and some nails but bullfrogs they come
down with your cell mate a bloke any
makes a noise like a bullfrog croak and
his throat enhances the size spiracle
hysterical you see it alright less then
yo I really must wish you're all listen
to the French band justice but this one
though I retain your respect I talked
about just it as a concept the lady
where in the blindfold
how is she maybe like 25 years old her
nipples pert and her breasts plump yeah
and I see that she'd get the hump if I
discuss it this way her main reward if
she gets to hold scale than the other
hand a sword put it in the scabbard run
the criminals through is that just
enough for you I just sit there yeah
that's what I like when I get a cold
drink I get just ice that is how I break
it down so low just as justice a port
monitor